welcome to know that the sort of local
girl and dirty men shirt reviews
millionaires in clean expensive clothing
I have been encouraged wo you know your
life is different now the SAG Awards
happened over the weekend not to be
confused with the sad Awards which
happened in my house I was the only
attendee I won Best Supporting Actress
for an ensemble cast in the comedy the
funny part is said there was no ensemble
the SAG Awards happened so let's review
those red carpet fashion this is some
reflecting from a window just closes I
get to going outdoors and a stone you
look very elegant and chic and like some
Mean Girls ripped have your dress off
before you got on the carpet you also
kind of look like maybe you were in the
bathroom and your publicist was like mm
oh gotta go we gotta go you're like I
can't get the rest of my dress on he
just walked out never was like
personalisation she can do no wrong you
know now of course if you see I love
Natalie Portman and I love that this has
reminded me that I need advice tissues
which I'm very thankful for because I'm
still coughing up mucus and running low
and throw pillows but you know what did
this my sex bucket like she's super
pregnant and these award shows are
uncomfortable for people that aren't
pregnant if I was super pregnant an
award show I want to wear a quilt too
this is very sharp sharp sharp sharp it
can be big and 2017 every girl at Hotel
is going to be wearing a tarp important
did it first yeah
my high who did she tell my experience
of enroll nice designed her psych awards
dress I love that she's Equal
Opportunity it also looks like there was
something else happening on the shoulder
that might have caught on fire the limo
on the way over but she's not going to
let that ruin her day is that ribbon or
like an adult leash around your waist
either way cute Michelle Williams you
look so sad your face looks like how all
of us are looking at the foot alignment
right now but you look glamorous you
look like a really glamorous roll of
wrapping paper yeah Kerry Washington oh
you always look so sexy this is like a
Jersey Shore bride is that white sequins
Christian I would say sneaky sneaky but
more like Snookie Snookie I'll see
myself out it's this way
no Janelle Monae okay I love this
because I love to nómine and only she
you can pull this off this is probably
confusing to a lot of people myself
included but it's unpredictable and
that's what I love about Janelle monáe's
unpredictable and that's what makes it
exciting and lovable like my period I
never know exactly when it's going to
show up but when it gets here I am just
so happy Julia Louie Dreyfus
oh you look chic and sleek and who said
vine is dead I hate me too brie Larson
this is very like modern glamour I can't
tell if the top of your dress is an
asymmetrical neckline or if your breasts
are just sort of moshing up in this area
either way cute Gina Rodriguez I love
this I think this looks so pretty sleek
and sophisticated but then it's quirky
and fun because there's birds that look
like they might be multiplied each other
right in this region very nature simple
and complicated all the same time who
doesn't love that an emotional sense
most dudes don't like that I've learned
so that's fun sandy Newton whoa this
dress tells a story and I might have
become illiterate but I love sandy
Newton she's talking awesome in
Westworld and so therefore I like this
dress that's how fashion math works but
like a ferris wheel or is that the Wheel
of Fortune wheel if it is the Wheel of
Fortune wheel can I buy a wow you look
great
nope
taraji what are you doing to me you look
amazing your eyebrows I've always look
amazing your boobs as always look
incredible who put those bows on you
someone pranked you with those bows
they're like too long kick me sign it
just look a little out of place but
that's okay because you make me feel out
of place in this universe because you're
just so good and that's cool so be our
Allah oh this is different for Sophia
usually she wears like full upgraded
prom dress chic and this is a short
coupon number and she looks very upset
with it we can click a 16 year old his
mom like forced her to wear like the
hand-me-down dress that her grandmother
gave to her to give to her for her
homecoming and she's not happy with it
but like I said Sophia is used to like a
full-length ballgown and you can tell
those ankles are a little insecure about
being exposed so I appreciate you
stepping out of your box Sophie ever got
mama
Shelby Turner this is great you look
great you just wake up once in a while
set some things to say Julie Bowen this
is really cute and sexy and elegant but
I think I might be actually looking at
her real vagina but I'm trying not to I
think the woman behind you is also
really me Kate Hudson made a lot of
choices with this ensemble I like to
imagine that she went to her stylist and
was like uh-uh we're not doing one
benzio top we're doing - I'm not wearing
the corsage around my wrists going
around my weight that tapes not going
around my neck or cutting it in half and
putting each tape on my shoulder
sounds like ma'am you're in a Starbuck
cute viola David don't you look like the
fanciest most elegant mother of the
bride she looks so sophisticated oh here
comes the weight of a feeling like an
actual bottle garbage chute Ellie Kemper
this is so pretty
blue velvet very trendy but still so
sophisticated
I'd say I'm a big big fan of Elvis it's
sad to announce that you're a fan of a
fabric kaley cuoco
hey Maisie Williams look oh the
Hollywood stop elegant email person more
descriptive words this is like Avril
Lavigne and Marilyn Monroe Freaky Friday
really cute girl Claire boy oh boy whoa
okay I feel like the dresses on the red
carpet say words but one of two ways
super simple elegant were like every
possible choice a dress that have on it
all at the same time and different the
latter but I don't hate it and that's
always a fun thing to say to another
human that's putting themselves out
there in a horrible way
a lot of choices have been made which is
great because you do better on your SATs
when you make a choice era winter winter
is coming
whoa this is super sexy but still like
elegant and young am I looking at a glow
up this is so good good for you girl
although those two men behind you are
like the stock image photo that comes up
a few Google image search old men really
own business the boys from stranger
things don't picture cool style these
guys and wider than a smile every single
man in Hollywood because these kids look
better on the last couple red carpets
that I've seen over the last like years
of reviewing them with the mended
Hollywood you got what right a green
suit and pinstripes and blue suede shoes
and just like classics you even know the
fashion risks that you're taking and the
fashion legacies that you're making also
I started following some of them on
Instagram and I feel weird about it
because they're children nearly Bobby
Brown aka the younger girl from stranger
things I feel like every photo I see
what I've heard on the red carpet gets a
little bit more mature and if style just
loves it more refined and a little bit
more defined to make it more personal to
her and I become a little bit better at
finding descriptive words [ __ ] my
way through fashion reviews yeah there
you go there's my review of the red
carpet fashions at the SAG Awards leave
a comment down below let me know who was
your favorite fashion thing at the
awards thing you like this video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up and click
this button to subscribe to this youtube
channel because I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday on an extreme
inconsistent but pleasant basis I don't
know Mary Hart look at you what's up
little gray I don't mean the sound shot
as if you don't always look great but
you look really beautiful here you were
in paint it is taking all of me not to
make a pink one in the stink joke right
now